- So welcome everyone,
to the Fall 2021 Refugees Seminar Series.
Today we have the pleasure
of having Professor Nugent
talking about the activism from exile
and how activists abroad
influence politics back home.
Professor Nugent is an Assistant Professor
of Political Science at Yale University.
She is the author of After Repression,
How Polarization Derails
Democratic Transition,
published by Princeton
University Press in 2020.
Her research explored
the political psychology
of religion and repression
in the Middle East,
and has been published or is forthcoming
in the American Journal
of Political Science,
Comparative political studies,
Journal of Conflict Resolution Proceedings
of the National Academy of
Science and/or politics.
Professor Nugent holds
a Doctorate in Politics
from Princeton University,
as well as a Bachelor in Arts in Arabic,
and Master in Arts in Arabic studies,
both from Georgetown University.
She previously was a
postdoctoral research fellow
in the Middle East Initiative
at Harvard Kennedy School of Government,
Belfer Center for Science
and International Affairs.
So this is our hybrid seminar,
we have attendees both in
the Luce Center and in so.
So Professor Nugent
the floor is yours, thanks.
- Great, well, thank you so
much for joining in Lewis.
And to everyone else who's joining online,
I really appreciate the program.
Over the last two years
that I've been working on this project,
it's obviously been quite
interrupted by the pandemic.
And the small grant that
I have from the program
allowed me to basically shift
a lot of what I was doing
to online research and online interviews
so I'll talk a little bit
about during the presentation.
So the broader project that
I'm gonna talk about today,
takes on start the Arab Spring
uprisings since 2011 to 2012.
This is a picture from Tahrir Square,
which was the epicenter of
the revolution in Egypt.
In my first book, I talked
a lot about how essentially
the revolution went wrong, right.
So how it resulted in
authoritarian retrenchment
within two years.
But one of the first quotes
that I cite in the book
is from somebody who was in Tampere,
for those 18 days of protests.
He described it as being like a dream.
So it felt like everything was possible,
there was a sense of camaraderie
with strangers and countrymen.
One author describes it
as liminality, right,
that everything that felt
like it had been established
was now up for question in really positive
and interesting ways.
And for a brief moment,
in the Egyptian case,
there was actually civilian government.
So from 2012 to 2013.
Chris was a Muslim Brotherhood affiliate,
but there was someone
who was not a military figure in charge.
The thing that within two years,
the revolution is essentially over.
What I'm gonna call it and I'll define
this in a couple of slides
is a defeated revolution.
This gentleman here Abdel Fattah al-Sisi
the current president of Egypt.
In July 2013, he announced
on national television
that the military would
be performing a coup,
removing the democratically
elected president from office.
He then won reelection twice
with kind of the standard
94 97% of the vote
and a pretty regular
authoritarian election.
Since then he's overseen
retrenchment of authoritarianism
and that's much worse than
what his predecessors oversaw.
So in the first year after the coup,
there were 40,000 people
that were arrested,
most affiliated with
the Muslim Brotherhood.
Since then, that number
has grown to 100,000
probably 60,000 of those
are political prisoners
and beyond Sisi has recently reached
his constitutional term limit
and so he pushed the new amendments
not only allowed him to
stay in power through 2030,
but also institutionalizing
military rule in the country.
So Egypt even though, it's
obviously a very heartbreaking
and sad story, it's also
not an anomalous story.
So most revolutions fail, right
two out of three since 1900 to 2014
there have been 345
revolutionary episodes.
Two thirds of those have failed.
Only 123 have actually resulted
in meaningful political,
economic or social change.
And what's interesting is
that despite its prevalence,
this is the modal outcome,
we know very little about
what happens afterwards.
We know a lot about
successful revolutions.
The literature tends to focus
on these are interesting,
and they're particularly
unique in certain ways.
So what I'm gonna talk about today
is a new book project
and a related paper on
taking efforts inspiration
because of what has happened
in Egypt over the last few years.
So I am particularly
interested in how activists
experience defeat of revolution,
and then how it affects their
subsequent political behavior.
I'm gonna start by giving you an overview
of my book tentatively titled
Exiles: How Activists Brought
Influence Politics Back Home.
What I'm gonna do in this
is kind of conceptualize
what defeated revolution is for activists,
these are people who are acutely
aware of what's going on.
They're also involved with both planning
and executing revolutions.
What I'm gonna argue is that
combination of experiences
and the context that they end up in,
as you'll see in the case of Egypt,
most activists who are not
in jail are now in exile,
because that's a quite a profound impact
on whether they continue
to be active as activists
and the nature of that activism.
And as I mentioned, I'm gonna focus
mostly on Egyptian exiles,
so Syrian, Iraqi and Libyan
exiles come up as an
interesting comparison.
Then I'm gonna talk about a related
but standalone coauthor paper
with Alex Siegel at the
University of Colorado Boulder.
She really is the expert
for dealing with Arabic
language, digital data.
What we do here is look at
a specific case of protests
in Egypt in September 2019,
where exiles were extremely influential
in introducing and then
amplifying information
that then resulted in
pretty significant protests.
So what comes after defeated revolution?
This is kind of a big
question that I'm interested
in this book.
I have a quote up here that
hopefully you can see online
as well I'll just read it.
This from Sarah Hegazi the
late Egyptian activists,
she said, "As Saint-Just
said, "those who make half
a revolution dig their own graves.'
It was literally, not
just figuratively true.
Most of us are now in the
grave, in prison or in exile."
Sarah was a communist
activist who died by suicide
following a pretty terrible ordeal.
She waved an LGBTQ pride flag
at a (indistinct) concert
in Cairo resulted in her
being arrested, tortured,
the PTS said that she
suffered from was pretty huge
she ended up in exile in Osho Canada.
So what is the experience
like for activists?
There are some obvious ways
that we can think about this.
First, there's a decrease
in the quality of democracy
in Egypt, right?
There was this one year civilian rule.
There were two years of elections,
there were two years of liberalization.
So activists were saying that's a decrease
in that quality specifically
and about politics, right?
If you remember that first
quote I just showed you.
At the beginning, it felt like a dream,
it felt like everything was possible
life was going to change significantly.
But politically, socially, economically,
personally, a number of people
that I talked to, for this project
have had major falling outs
with family and friends
in ways that also toxic
to the personal aspects
of defeated revolution.
In addition, especially
in the case of Egypt,
the instability that the
revolution introduced
among its defeat, exacerbated,
these folks are gonna be
exposed to economic decline.
But most importantly,
and this is why I told
you Sarahs backstory,
and a moment of defeat of revolution,
the state is going to be quite defensive.
They're reestablishing themselves.
What happened is that activists
are those that are targeted most acutely
by state repression.
As I mentioned, 100,000
have been arrested,
60,000 of those are political prisoners.
Countless have been
disappeared into the system,
their lawyers and their
families can't find them.
What I'm gonna focus on here
is this group of individuals
who have been exiled
so there's potentially 10s of
1000s, who have been exiled.
This is a form of course migration
that functions in a way that's
very similar to regression.
So before I get too much further,
let me define a couple of terms
just so we're all on the same page here.
So first, the way that
I think of revolution
is a massive of established government,
involving competing claims to sovereignty,
which aims to displace
the incumbent regime
and substantially alter
the established order.
Now, scholars will often differentiate
between political revolutions
right where the established order
that's being changed as political.
My interlocutors really
think of political,
social and economic
changes going together.
So the established order here
is to the society at large.
What I mean by defeated revolution
is when this process
doesn't happen, right,
so the competing senators
of sovereignty emerge,
the way Tilly talks about this,
there's a revolutionary situation,
there's a potential for change,
and it doesn't result
in the final instance,
and meaningful change to
the established order.
I think it's a bit differently
than other scholars
in political science do.
Often there's a focus on
the sequence or process
through which revolutions emerge,
or the structural
predecessors that determine
whether or not a revolution
is successful eventually.
But I'm thinking about this
as a participatory experience.
So something that happens to activists
not necessarily something that they do.
Second, activists, this is a definition
I take from (inaudible) an individual
with long-term involvements in the form
of collective protest action,
in the context of movements,
groups, or campaigns
that were structured to
at least some extent.
Two parts that I wanna highlight here.
So first, long-term involvements
isn't an important thing,
activists or people who think of activism
as a political behavior that they use
not just in the revolutionary situation
that I just referred to
but as a way of contesting
politics more broadly.
In the case of Egypt, this means
that they're not just active in 2011.
They're active before 2011,
and they're active since.
Second, this definition
speaks to the collective.
So individual protests is very interesting
but it's hard to generalize,
it's hard to observe.
Here being involved in movements, groups,
unions, organizations, things
that are collective entities
is really important for
thinking about somebody
as being an activist.
And then finally, exile is
just one of the key terms
in the book project.
So as I mentioned, that
results from course migration
regimes use this as a
political punishment,
for political behavior.
It's very similar to other logics
in terms of why regimes use it.
So the idea here is to
demobilize individuals,
fracture the opposition, make
anti-regime mobilization,
unsuccessful and ineffective.
One thing that became very
obvious in my research
is that this is a difficult
thing to sometimes pin down.
One thing that happens to people,
or one kind of migration
status that exiles hold.
So the way I talk about this in the book
is that there are both explicit
and formal forms of exile,
and then implicit and
informal forms of exile.
So let's start with
explicit informal here,
the focus is going to be on
revocation of citizenship,
or travel ban, with informal,
it's much more the regime
shows up at your house
in the form of the police,
makes it very evident
that you're no longer a protected citizen,
less formal, but still
just as potentially scary.
Additional thing that I've
found in some of my research,
so often, exiles will also
talk about the decline
in the quality of politics
and economics in Egypt
as a reason for why they left.
So I'm trying to think
about how that might also
be regime strategies,
or a tactic of wanting people to leave.
So where have Egypt's
activist gone since 2011?
Both of these graphs on
the next one are inflows,
and then asylum claims to OECD countries.
As you can see, 2011 is
gonna be this dotted line.
This is the year of the revolution.
2013 is about here.
So these are major events.
First, the revolution
and the (indistinct).
In the decade is prior to the revolution,
there are about 239,000 Egyptian
migrants to OECD countries.
That number grows to 339,000 after.
We can see an even
bigger spike here, right.
So before the revolution,
about 13,000 Egyptians
had applied for asylum in OECD countries,
but 10 years after the revolution,
116,000 had applied for asylum.
So significant numbers,
particularly after 2011.
That's kind of interesting, right?
I mean, in a case like
Syria, the revolutions
led to a civil war, the
security context have declined.
We might expect a graph like this.
And in fact the numbers are quite large,
but Egypt hasn't become any safe,
any less safe in terms
of national security
in the last few years.
So there's clearly something
politically motivated going on.
From my quality of evidence,
and my interviews with activists,
one thing that I've uncovered
is that the demographics of migrants
have changed over the last 10 years.
So the Brotherhood, its
activists and supporters,
its leaders, those who weren't arrested,
left 2013, essentially, as the coup
is happening (indistinct).
And in 2014, the CC
regime having more or less
dealt with the Brotherhood and involves
legal and repressive waves starts to look
at the rest of the active opposition
and starts to target
Non-Islamic activists.
And they start to leave in
larger numbers starting in 2014.
And then again, in 2018,
right around the elections.
What's been interesting is watching
the self of activists popping
up in different locations
over the last 10 years.
So there are certain Western
destinations in Germany
and we have Berlin, in the
US, there's New York City
and Washington DC.
There's also places closer to the region,
including Doha and Instabul.
Interestingly, there are three interesting
places of exiles of Italy, Milan, Korea,
and Seoul and Lebanon, Beirut.
This has to do with the
ease of which victims
can travel to these places.
They don't need visas to
go into these countries,
particularly in Seoul,
this was an early hub.
And since the migration restrictions
have actually been put down,
so there's not as many
people migrating there.
So the broader question
I'm asking in this project
is what's been interesting
is watching how activism
does or doesn't change once
people left the country, right.
So first, what influences
whether activists
continue to be activists in exile.
And second, what influences
that form, right.
What they're doing as activism.
As a first choice, so
here we have activism,
we have our activists who
are then being exiled.
In the first order, they
have three main choices.
They cease to be activists
as individual demobilization,
they leave the movement
they leave activism,
do they convert?
This is the term that I use here.
So they start to mobilize on other issues.
Concrete example of this
might be Egyptian activists
in exile in Berlin had to start
to work on migration issues
in Germany, or the Green Movement.
So we no longer focus on
domestic issues in Egypt.
If they continue to mobilize on Egyptian
based domestic issues,
they have three main behavioral choices.
Do they work as an activist
to prepare the movement
for regime change down the road?
Or do they take a combative approach
either promoting bottom up regime change
through support networks
back home on the ground,
or promoting top down
regime change by lobbying
their new hosts in their new countries?
The theoris in how they
make these decisions,
I think both combination of individual
and contextual factors come into play,
but at different times
during the decision process.
So in terms of individual factors,
I think this is really important
for that first decision, right?
Whether or not you continue in activism,
convert to activism, or
cease to be an activist.
Here looking at some of the literature
on the biographical effects of activism,
we see that the length
of activism matters.
So people who joined activism before 2011
tend to be much more committed
in ways that suggests
they're going to continue
even after they leave their country.
The existence of personal
networks back home.
Can the regime literally
repress your family,
even though you're no longer part
of kind of the domestic sphere.
Experiences of repression
can go one of two ways.
So some people who experienced
repression and torture
as a result of the
defeat of the revolution,
they're galvanized, they're angry,
the parts of their identity
for which they were repressed are stronger
and more mobilizing.
For other people they have real trauma,
real PTSD in ways that prevent
them from being an activist.
Then finally, I consider
two demographic conditions,
the first class and education.
So do you have the literal resources
that you need to continue
to be an activist,
particularly when it's very difficult?
And secondly, are you in a phase of life
where you may be working on other things,
like education or even having children.
This in the American literature
is particularly important
for why people individually
didn't rise from activism.
In terms of the contextual factors,
I'll look at three things,
the first regime type,
this is democracy where
people have the ability
to lobby their representatives,
have their preferences
accounted for in policies,
what are the relationships like
between the new host country
and the home country?
You'll see them in my cases
there's a very big difference
between the United
States, Germany and Turkey
in terms of the relationship with Egypt.
And then finally thinking about migration,
the extent to which migrants
have essentially assimilated
which has to do with
the number of migrants
how they're treated, whether
or not there are other
similar migrants who are
treated similarly to them.
In this case, Arab and Muslim migrants,
matters for whether or not
they're going to keep mobilizing
on domestic issues back home,
or issues related to the new host country.
So putting this all together,
this is the data that I'm working with,
it's a mixed activism project.
Much of this has been delayed by COVID.
But I'm hopeful that it's
gonna get done in 2022.
As I mentioned, the program's funding
allowed me to complete a data
set of Egyptian migration,
a data set of travel
bans and arrests in Egypt
under the CC regime,
and also to keep translating
and transcribing my semi
structured interviews,
which I was able to complete
(indistinct) the last 18 months.
So just a couple of notes on
some preliminary findings.
These two gentlemen
were both administrating
the (indistinct) Facebook pages
was an extremely important
Facebook page that organized
the protests in 2011,
from the top we have Abdullah al-Nadeem
on the bottom, we have Abdulla Rasha.
both of them have
experienced course migration,
they were both arrested, tortured.
Both of them have experienced
having family members
questioned by the regimes.
They reacted in very different ways.
So right there on the top, he
now lives in San Francisco,
he's really no longer what
we might call an activist.
He does do some individual mobilization,
but he's disconnected from
the networks of people
that he worked with before,
set a couple of very public sad meltdowns,
I guess he would call them
and he now works in the tech industry.
Abdullah al-Nadeem remains very networked,
he's now living in New York City,
continues to very quietly mobilize
among both the German and the
American networks of exiles.
Let me speak a little bit about
the importance of context.
In the United States,
there's been an interesting
development of the Egypt
Human Rights Caucus.
This is led by in Congress,
it's Don Beyer and Tom Malinowski,
I believe in Virginia and New Jersey.
Here, activists have been
working on forming this caucus
to talk about things like human rights
and military aid to Egypt.
So it's very specific, right?
We're not talking about
regime change here.
And that has very much
to do with the nature
of the relationship between
Egypt and the United States.
It's also shaped by the
political opportunity structure.
So here before the caucus,
they're lobbying the government
because that's how politics
works the United States.
In the case of Germany, you
see a much more diffuse,
less organized, less
hierarchical structure.
There tends to be a lot
of cross pollination,
Berlin has a huge Syrian exile population.
And so you see Egyptians working
in kind of pan Arab issues.
This is a protest that Egyptians
worked with Palestinians
to mobilize these issues.
There's some mobilization
in terms of lobbying
the government or testifying
in front of the government
on certain issues but it
can be much more diffused,
much more focused
on what we would call
traditional activism.
So now, I wanna get
into the coauthored paper with Alexival.
In this case, we're gonna be looking
at specifically protests in Egypt in 2019.
And how exiles participated in introducing
and mobilizing these protests.
The broader question we're asking
is how do exiles participate
in contentious politics
back home in the digital age?
And to theorize this we draw
on three sets of literature
and some of their essential concepts.
So first, we think of the internet
as extending the domestic sphere abroad.
So this is a place in which
there's a transnational
sense of political identity,
exiles who're no longer physically
located within the country
can to continue to be in
contact and even deepen
certain kinds of connections
with people back home.
And it essentially allows
political exiles to have agency
to have some kind of autonomy
in influencing domestic politics.
Second, we rely on the political models
of how we think about people
and how they've joined
activists protests mobilization,
to think about what the internet
might be doing similarly
to these classic models.
So we know the individual
models of protests,
mobilization, that information provision
is extremely important, right.
So learning that lots of other people
support oppositional position
makes it less costly for
the individual to join.
What we're thinking
about here is digital
information provision.
And here, this, again, speaks
to the the classic models,
but we're talking about essentially
when something goes viral online.
So when things are posted
by multiple people,
in a way that suggests that
lots of people support it.
This is important for
authoritarian regimes
in a way that may be less
important for democratic issues.
So online, it's slightly more free,
at least in the context of Egypt,
it may be the kind of place where engaging
with oppositional information
here meeting critical of the regime
signal something read about how popular
an oppositional position is.
And then finally, we think that exiles
might actually have quite
a unique role to play
in digital information cascade.
So as you saw exiles
obviously are all located
outside of the country.
None of them are located
in democratic contexts
where they have relatively more impunity,
to be posting oppositional information,
and doing so over time
and connects us in a way
that had they been in the country,
they might have been
repressed or (indistinct).
To think about how this
whole process works,
we draw by the communication
literature talk
about three different kinds
of social media users.
So first influencers these are the users
that see new content, they
make memes, they make hashtags.
This case, they also make videos,
some of the literature
first time as idea starters.
There's amplifiers, these
are, as the literature
calls them firehose of knowledge,
they're doing all for lack of
a better word amplification,
of this information.
So taking the content, making it go viral.
These are extremely important users,
because they're often very active.
They'll do things like in the
case under consideration here.
They're going to retreat at a high rate.
They're going to add
people to conversations
and then connect people.
Then finally we have consumers.
In our theory these are also gonna end up
being the protest participants.
Some of the literature
calls these people lurkers,
they consume content,
they look at content,
they might be on the internet quite a bit,
but they're not doing a
lot of public engagement.
They might not be retweeting
or liking information
in a way that we can capture publicly.
What we think, going into that,
so what we in fact find is that exiles
are particularly influential
when they are influencers
introducing that new information,
and when they're amplifying it as well
because of the relative
impunity that they can act with.
But it's really important
that there is overlap
in the amplifier and consumer categories
with domestic users.
Otherwise, it's just an
excellent mobilization
and excellent movement.
So the case that we're gonna be talking
about comes from September 2019 in Egypt.
This is Mohamed Ali.
He in this video is located
in Spain, in self exile.
Prior to leaving Egypt,
he had worked for 15 years
as a contractor for the Egyptian
military, and construction.
He also worked as an actor,
which will become important
for thinking through
some of our general
generalizability from this case.
In his videos, which he starts posting
on September 2nd 2018.
He calls out the current
regime for corruption.
He called the two major generals by name,
they've been in charge
of the Armed Forces Engineering Authority.
He claims that he's owed
220 million Egyptian pounds.
And he talks about all this
corruption with experience.
The Sisi regime has been
spending quite a bit of money,
constructing a new capital,
constructing these villas for
the military on the Red Sea.
And so he's speaking to best rate,
he witnessed firsthand
quite a bit of corruption.
The president actually responds to him
after a full week of videos.
And then the hours after that response
happens, Mohamed Ali this
gentleman right here,
posts a number of videos
and pretty shifts from
being specifically focused
on corruption to calling
for wider protests,
broader issues of
corruption, and repression.
He posts videos from a number
of long-term activists,
so assign an activist and
also a former Army officer
and lawyer who now works in human rights.
He's also reposting a lot of videos
that are coming from both mass
and identified individuals
claiming to be members of the armed forces
who support the claims of peacemaking.
I should note, they all get channeled
through all these accounts in a way
that makes it really helpful for us
to basically track how this
process unfolds over time.
So the first protests
happen on (indistinct) yeah.
- [Man] Just a quick question.
So does Mohamed Ali have some of family
back in Egypt as we
presume he (indistinct)?
- He has some, I know,
after all this plays out,
there's pressure that's
put on him (indistinct).
Then I can talk a little bit
more about that (indistinct).
But I should just know.
So he has both a YouTube account
where he's posting these videos,
he has a Twitter account where
he's retweeting this content.
And then he also spreads most
of these things on Facebook,
through different hashtags.
So these are new protests.
They protested on 20th,
the 21st and then the 27th.
Though the 27th are going
to be the largest ones.
The regime responds in two ways.
So these moments of mobilization,
the people fled the streets with police,
especially made of
squares where these groups
tend to congregate and start protests.
They arrest 4321 individuals
as a result of participating
in these protests.
They also used Twitter's
reporting mechanism
to shut down all these account,
I'll be able to show you
that in a couple of slides from now.
And at some 150 accounts
of related activists
who are highly engaged with his content.
So to figure out what's
going on here, right?
How do exiles this, Mohamed Ali
and those that interact with him,
how do they introduce information
that then mobilizes protest,
well he use a method
called process tracing.
So this is the analysis
of diagnostic evidence,
patterns of evidence
from processes, sequences
and conjunctures of events
within a single case.
And process tracing is particularly good
for looking at the specific
causes of specific outcomes.
In this case, what we do
is look at the introduction
of information, the
amplification of information,
the consumption of information,
and our last analysis to break that down
at a very fine grained sub national level
in a way that suggests this information
consumption predicts protest mobilization
at a very local level.
The digital data we have both captures
public and private
engagement with this content.
Facebook, we're gonna
have data from public,
Facebook pages, community pages.
Google Trends is more of a private way
to think about engagement
with this content.
It's basically search trends
that are just aggregated by location.
Twitter allows us to again get
that public engagement.
So are people adding Mohamed Ali?
Are they retweeting?
Are they liking?
Ans finally YouTube is again,
a bit more private, right?
So when you think about likes and dislikes
that you can post on a YouTube
page, what's more public,
but there's also information
about viewing a video
that we have.
The non-digital data that we use here
is from Dafta Ahwal.
It's a Cairo based organization
that does real time data
collection on contentious events.
So first thinking about our influencer,
as I mentioned, he starts in September 2,
between September 2 and November 1,
which is our period of analysis,
he posts between one
and seven videos a day.
There's the front end,
but he's very active
throughout this period.
He started a Twitter account the same day
he posted his first video
and so he goes from having
very I mean literally
zero followers to skip this
is the number of tweets right?
So he starts from having very few tweets
to producing almost 6000 by
the time this period is over.
There are different moments
when you can figure out
the regime is starting to interfere.
Some of these early ones.
Every time there's a vertical line
Tweet has been deleted.
Some of these early ones are
Mohamed Ali censoring himself.
These are much more likely
based on secondary information
to be the regime shutting
down (indistinct).
Here is his follower account.
So as I mentioned he starts
with very few followers,
by the time of the first protest
he has 250,000 followers.
So he's becoming central, very influential
within certain networks of activists
in a way where he's the central node.
We can see this happening here.
Now to turn to the amplifiers.
Here, we have Twitter data
that we collected in real time.
And we're able to see, first of all,
that these trends in terms of engagement,
again either retweeting or adding,
literally replying or tagging him.
It corresponds with the
protests that are happening.
We also disaggregate it by users
who are located inside of
Egypt and outside of Egypt.
What you can see here is
that the rates of engagement
inside Egypt at least in this
manner are higher overall,
and consistently so than outside of Egypt.
What we do next to
understanding the top amplifiers
is take the 100 top engagers,
we manually code whether or
not they're located in Egypt,
outside of Egypt, what
their nationality is,
and know what their profession
is or what sector they worked in depending
or relying on information that they post
in their own Twitter bios.
A lot of people will
link to a LinkedIn page
or professional website.
So from this, I should
know the notes will appear
larger if they're central.
So if they're being engaged quite a bit.
Here this is Mohamed Ali's account.
So what you can see here
is that the top amplifiers
even though I just showed you
that most of the engagements
coming from inside of Egypt,
the top amplifiers are
located outside of Egypt.
So they're doing a lot of this
amplification that matters.
Second, they're Egyptians.
So they're Egyptians
that are located outside
of the country, again suggesting
that there's this
transnational political sphere
where things are being spread.
And that matters.
I mean, it makes them much more credible
in terms of why they would be interested
in this information, why
they would be spreading it.
Finally, when we look into the after type,
what we find is that there
are a number of media
personalities that are
extremely influential
and active in terms of
amplifying Mohamed Ali's content.
And these individuals,
when we looked into the
data tend to be part
of the anti CC Independent
Media Base in Germany.
This will become important
in just a couple of slides.
These are particularly
influential kinds of users.
They're deemed credible.
They're somehow celebrities
in ways that matter
for against the spread of information.
There's also high numbers
of politicians and exiles,
activists and academics.
All of them are exile
outside of the country.
Finally, one more slide here
on thinking through amplification,
as I mentioned and
Mohamed Ali use hashtags
that call not only for being anti-regime,
but also for specific protests.
Here, we can see again
inside and outside Egypt
are engaging these hashtags
at very similar rates.
And it corresponds with
some of the larger protests,
and this is gonna be September 27,
is a huge spike, similar to here.
Again suggesting right
that this information
matters for mobilization.
Finally, trying to
consumers, as I mentioned,
these are most likely to be
the protesters in our story.
We start with YouTube data.
September 2nd is when these
videos are gonna be posted.
There's a huge spike,
initially, almost
500,000 views in one day.
There's also an interesting
backlash effect.
So by October 15, the Egyptians data
stepped in really shut down protests.
Doesn't seem to make the
content any less popular.
And I should say that in
this period of analysis,
there's 3.3 million views.
So this is a pretty viral video.
We also see that these numbers
are not gonna be anywhere
near a majority of people
watching this content.
But when people publicly
get to that they tend
to be more positive, right?
So they're liking the video on YouTube
at a much higher rate
than they are just like.
And again, these trends
correlate not only with protests,
but with views more generally.
Now, the difficult part of
what we're trying to do here
is linking information
consumption with protest behavior.
That's something obviously
happens on an individual level,
it's hard to capture.
So what we try to do is first
we break it down by Gov.
So this is the Google Trends data,
again, much more of a private approach
to thinking about people
engaging with this content.
We seek relative interest concentrated
in the Red Sea govenor Kena
damietta, Cairo, and Giza.
Yes, but I can say the
outside of the Red Sea gov,
which for various reasons,
is highly policed.
This is where most of the
tourism in Egypt happens.
The Red Sea is also important.
So it's very highly pleased.
Everywhere but the Red Sea
saw the largest number of protests
between three and 11 in
the period under analysis.
But we want to think about this
in a much more fine grained level.
So what we do is look at the protest data,
everywhere that more
than one protest happen,
is listed here.
So these are our most active spaces.
And it's interesting
they're in Suez and Cairo,
jarhead and urban, but
they're also in the middle
of nowhere in Egypt.
What we do is match these districts
account essentially to an American County,
with districts that are the same
in terms of level of governance.
Morsi vote in 2012.
So something about opposition to the state
or anti-Islamist population.
But they don't have any protest.
What we do that is find
public Facebook pages.
You might be familiar with these,
these are community pages where people
talk about things like
schools and potholes
and broken streetlights.
What we do is scrape it to see
if they're talking about any of this
right at a very local level.
And we find that they're talking
about the oppositional content
in very different ways.
So this, the blue here
is going to be places
where protests occurred.
The pink is going to be places
where they did not occur.
What we see here is that
places where protests occurred,
talked about Mohamed Ali's
oppositional content,
posted it, discussed it, prior
to the start of protests.
And then they stopped talking about it.
And we think there's some
kind of repressive backlash
there where they're no longer willing
to talk about something
that is potentially costly.
In the non-protest areas,
they only talk about that
content after protests.
So they're learning something
about this oppositional contract
from likely that nationwide
news coverage of these events.
So we think of this the
quality of literature
is much more of a smoking gun.
Just there is something about
local information consumption
of this oppositional information
that matters for whether
or not you see protests
or whether or not you're learning
about that information later.
So just to recap
here exiles in our story
are really important
for introducing and
amplifying information.
They contribute to information cascades,
which are so important for
getting people to protest,
but they don't lead interest rate.
You'll remember in all of the graphs,
there was more online
engagement from domestic users
than exile users.
Finally, we show that there's
a very fine grained level
of correlation between local protests
and local consumption of this
oppositional information.
As I mentioned, there may be two things
that are somewhat specific to this case,
although we're only looking at Egypt,
it would certainly be
worth thinking about Egypt
in comparative perspective.
The influencer is not only credible
as the kid say, has received from having
been personally involved in
being an army contractor,
he's not partisan.
In a place like Egypt being identified
as either an Islamist or non Islamist,
in meaningful ways might
have made his information,
less credible to lots of people.
On the other side, he emphasizes
throughout his videos,
his blue colored background,
which is kind of an every
man in the situation.
As I mentioned, he also
worked as a celebrity.
So he's very polished,
he's very charismatic,
his videos are shot in
like a selfie style,
but they're very polished.
Second, because he works in
the entertainment industry,
he seems to have a lot of followers
who are in the media and
the entertainment sectors.
And in the literature
in the United States,
people tend to be bored of politics,
they don't like politics.
Celebrities can get people
excited about politics.
And so he has a high
number of these people
who are considered to be icons
in the communications literature
that are retweeting
especially Ali in his work.
So to bring it back to a higher level,
what I'm hoping to do here
is think about the micro foundations
of both revolution and
defeated revolution,
as well as democratization.
So quite a few of the activists
that I am talking about,
in both the paper that
I'm working on with Alex
and in the book, these are people
who not only planned and
executed the revolution,
but they continued it to be
completed continued beyond 2011.
And the political science literature
has talked a lot about how
their biographical effects
of having participated in movements.
Here, I'm interested in this concept
of how participating in a revolution,
and then a defeated revolution
affect the rest of your life.
For many new people that
happen in their early 20s.
They solve a long time to
grapple with the effects
and it's completely under
studied and literature.
Second, I'm interested in kind of doing
this and other projects as well
with one of our colleagues
here, Dan Natali.
Course migration is a very
interesting form of migration.
And we spend a lot of
time in political science
thinking about transnational
repression, right?
What regimes are doing to punish activists
beyond their borders.
But we think less about
how this is inadvertently
creating transnational opposition.
And so we wanna think a
little bit more critically
about that how the way in which regimes
use course migration, if
they use course migration,
shapes opposition in ways
that has important effects
on domestic politics.
And finally, perhaps, hopefully,
a lot of this has not
been particularly helpful.
The folks that are currently
located outside of Egypt
who are doing things like introducing
oppositional information
and mobilizing protests
will likely be a source of
democratization in the future.
Most of the Arab Spring uprisings
did not result in a
meaningful democratization,
they very much resulted in
increased authoritarianism.
As a result, most of the
open space for contestation
is outside of the country.
So just like 2010, to 2011,
the Arab Spring uprisings
rely on decades of people
working as activists,
I think, any kind of
future democratization too.
And in the case of the Arab Spring,
right where we are now
with regards to oppression,
likely those activists
are gonna be the ones
located outside of the country.
So with that, I will say thank you,
thank you again, to the
program for helping me
to continue this research
over the last year.
- You're Welcome.
- So what do I do now?
(laughing)
- (indistinct) the
people from the audience
would like to ask questions now.
Pass them to Professor Nugent.
- Yeah, true.
- [Man] So I have two questions.
So the first is sort of a
sugary governing framing
or the types of cases that
your analysis applies to.
And I was wondering whether
this just applies to exile
in the context of defeated revolution,
or if it's broadly
applicable to any setting
where perhaps there's history
democratic backsliding.
So I was thinking particularly
in the case of Turkey,
but then also in settings
where one side is defeated
in a civil war, and individuals
are forced to go abroad,
but still there some attempt to try
and influence politics back home.
So like, I was wondering, the extent
to which you think your argument applies
to those settings that like
revolutionary settings,
in particular, whether
it can apply to a broader
set of settings?
And then the second
question I have is regarding
the diagram that you had
where individuals abroad
have these choices to either remain active
in politics back home as exiles,
or just change to some
other political activism
or just disengage altogether.
I was wondering the extent
to which individuals
shift between those modes of behavior.
But overall, really fascinating project.
- Should I answer it?
okay, yeah, so your first question
is a really interesting one,
because as I mentioned at
the beginning of the talk
of the 345 revolutionary situations
that don't, so 123 of them
are successful, right,
meaning they result in
democratization in a meaningful way.
The rest of them fail in
lots of different ways.
So some become civil wars,
some just go back to the
same authoritarianism.
Some go back to worse authoritarianism.
My case Kelly Clark has done
some really interesting work
on this concept of counter revolution.
Egypt and I think he's right on this,
although I think the concept
of defeated revolution
can apply to a lot of different things.
He calls it counter revolution,
where you actually did
have a civilian government,
or a change in the Old
Guard in a meaningful way.
And I think he says that there's 22 cases
of that, where you have
meaningful change in government
and then a reversal.
So I think, at the very least,
it applies to those 22 cases.
Some of the other cases that
I'm looking at in the book,
so Iraq, you end up with exiles before,
like, basically, under Saddam Hussein,
that's not necessarily the
result of a failed revolution.
In Libya, you also part
of that, there are moments
of civil war, there's also moments
of just higher oppression.
In Syria, it's a defeat a revolution
that has become a civil war.
So it's not exactly, it's both right.
That you can't separate that both
of these things are related.
So I'm trying to think
about defeated revolution
as a broad category, but
then there would be lots
of different ways that
revolutions are failed or failing.
Yeah, and in terms of that graph,
I mean, I think there
probably is some switching.
And at this point, it's been interesting
to see over the last 10 years,
how people have evolved
in their stance, right?
So people who have gone from
thinking that revolution
is pointless that thinking,
Okay, well, now the
revolution must be global
instead of local, it
does seem like most folks
who decide to cease being an activist
stay out of politics.
That's not the case for
every single person,
but for the most part
they're making choices
based on personal decisions,
their children in or their family
in needing to go back to
school, financial necessity,
or they've experienced such
a terrible form of oppression
like they're unable to keep
being active politically.
There is more flip flopping or changing
within people who continue to
be active on domestic issues,
and those who start to think about things
as a broader issue.
But it's pretty clear
when someone's saying,
okay, I'm mobilizing the
cause of political detainees
in Egypt versus political detainees.
And thinking about this in Egypt.
The way in which they talk
about it does differentiate
between whether they're thinking
about it as a broad category,
or if it's like in Egypt
specifically, this is the issue.
So yeah, I think there's more overlap
in those two categories.
As people frankly, come to terms
with, are they gonna be staying
in their new location for longer?
What else is happening in their life?
Are there new focal points right around
which they could be
bringing the Egyptian issue
into like the green movement
or into the migration movement?
Some of it's a bit strategic
in terms of that as well, yeah.
- [Man] Thanks, so I had two
questions, one for each part.
So for the first part of the talk,
I was curious what the city mentioned
while and Abdulla taking
different paths in their activism,
I was wondering if you had a sense
of why their paths diverged.
And you mentioned trauma
and I know they were
both exposed to trauma,
but I'm not sure if you have any insight
on why their paths might have taken
such different trajectories.
And then the second question that I had
is, you mentioned
transnational repression,
and how Moh Ali was shut down eventually.
And so I wonder, what if
you could talk a little bit
about how exile activism
differs from activism at home,
if you are still at the mercy
of transnational repression,
if your family members can
be targeted by the regime.
Is it just like an
oversight that the regime
didn't notice these people,
but then once they pop
up, they get shut down?
Or I feel like there there
could be some dynamic there.
Strategically, that would be
interesting to think about.
- Yeah, these are good questions.
So in terms of the individual variation,
I think in the case of
and Abdulla obviously,
people are quite idiosyncratic,
but I think in this case, it had to do
with their individual reactions
to trauma and repression.
So they had very similar experiences.
I think one of them as a
result had really terrible PTSD
resulted in a crumbling
of his both his personal
and professional and political life.
The other one channeled
it in different ways.
So I think that's probably
what's explaining that variation.
Second wait so this idea
of professional repression,
goes to your question too.
So initially, they're not
directly repressing Mohamed Ali.
They do shut down his account,
every time there's kind
of those vertical spikes,
you can see that either
things are being deleted
or the account has been shut down.
So I think online transnational repression
is particularly interesting
because essentially costless for a regime.
The other kinds of
transnational repression
that I was referring
to, in the case of Ali
is that they pressure some
of his family back home,
and then the Egyptian
state has been investing
and kind of its overseas
repression or surveillance.
They've been beefing up
the intelligence collection
at their embassies.
And what Ali claims in some later videos
is that he is being trailed
by an Egyptian puja.
So I think there's a couple things.
I think the fact that
Sisi responded to him
made him more credible.
You see the spikes,
there's clearly a reaction.
And I think he did so
because the information
that Ali was putting out
was particularly damning.
Although that was probably
a badly calculated risk.
Had he ignored it maybe it
wouldn't have gone viral
the way it did.
Yeah I mean, I think regimes
make mistakes on these things,
they either don't notice,
or they think it's not that big a deal.
I think once the 27th happened,
those were pretty large protests,
particularly in a country right now
where tightly repressive.
After that, I mean, I
think you see the regime
and then say, okay we
really need to squash this,
both in terms of physical presence,
and shutting down those
accounts and trailing Ali.
So I mean, in some ways this
time periods aren't that long,
it's between September
2nd, and September 27th
where we get an
introduction of information,
and then major protest.
So I guess they're moving
as quickly as they can.
That might be part of it, too.
- [Man] Thank you.
- [Woman] I have actually
had question as well.
So it's regarding the ability
of the regime to shut down
the way that the activists communicate.
So some of these, I imagine that they use
some of Facebook, Whatsapp.
So is there like any
pressure on these companies
both inside and outside to just shut down
whatever the regime is not liking
and what would be also the reaction
for the activist themselves,
maybe to transfer to use
another way of communicating
that cannot be survey the same point.
- Yeah, absolutely, so
in terms of the first.
So the pressure on my
accompany is that in this case
they shut down.
They use Twitter if you're
familiar with Twitter,
you can report content for
various reasons it's offensive,
or it's politically inflammatory.
It seems like what the regime
did was flag Arabic language content,
said it was inflammatory.
Twitter immediately removed those accounts
and that content.
Eventually, I don't really know
what goes on behind the scenes,
but eventually it was reviewed.
And I found that it wasn't actually
politically inflammatory
and so they reinstated the accounts.
There was also a couple of Twitter threads
where people were
collecting names of people
who had been targeted.
So then there was a sense
of, okay, all these people
were tweeting about this thing,
that's not politically inflammatory,
it's just oppositional information.
And there was an investigative report done
by a journalist outside of the country.
I think I have another graph
here of one additional thing,
in addition to shutting down the accounts,
the Egyptian state.
Let me see, no, I don't have it.
They are able
to basically make certain
websites unavailable.
And you can see access
to Twitter and Facebook,
if I had the graph you could see
but it's basically limited by 20 to 30%,
at different moments.
So they're able to do it on
a couple different levels.
But this investigative
journalist demonstrated,
it wasn't because they were saying
something like use violence or whatever
it was really, they were just
retweeting this information.
And I do think what I
really enjoy about activists
is that we're able to use sources
from a bunch of different platforms,
or data from a number
of different sources.
We do see that these things
are happening in tandem,
so there's a lot of
the information cascade
is happening across different platforms.
Obviously there's also secret ways to talk
about this stuff, WhatsApp and Signal
they're obviously doing that as well.
It's just harder to find public
data on that kind of stuff.
There's been some interesting papers
on also like Telegram and Clubhouse
ways that people when the
internet gets shut down,
when Facebook gets shut down,
when Twitter's being
monitored using Clubhouse
can sometimes be an alternative to that.
So they're definitely being strategic
in terms of that as well.
But their regime have they shut down,
or what is their approach
to these companies
working inside the (indistinct).
- Yeah, I mean, this is
a very timely question.
Some of the debates about like,
what role is Facebook
supposed to play in society.
Generally, in a democracy in an autocracy,
for the most part they've
been fine with them existing,
they just also put limitations on it.
Like Facebook Messenger is a way
that a lot of Egyptians
communicate in country.
I think they know, it's
like non encrypted,
there certain things you don't say there.
Yeah, at different
moments, I think WhatsApp
has been difficult to
access in the region,
because there's been a block on it.
So the regimes are clearly
using the technology
that they can to make it more difficult
to do this kind of coordination.
It's still easier to like police a street,
though, than to police an online platform.
So that tends to be where
they're focusing their efforts.
- Great, any more questions (indistinct).
- [Man] Yeah so in the second
project, the fair comparison
of the districts is really interesting.
And I was wondering if you
happen to have there's data out
there that you could, where
you could do that same
comparison but then see if
those matching districts
have different levels of protest activity
during the Arab Spring,
like eight years earlier.
And, like the extent to which there's been
a longer term legacy of
Arab Spring mobilization
that can then contribute
to the post counter revolutionary period
and the propensity of people (indistinct)
maybe it's like a (indistinct).
- Yeah, I don't have that.
But that's a really great suggestion.
We do see that, one thing we wondered
was whether they were more active anyway.
And there's no clear pattern here.
So the protests on average,
the protest localities
are slightly more active,
but not significantly.
So in terms of just number of posts,
our measurement ends up being
a percentage of total posts.
But I can't say that they're
at least not like significantly
different in terms of
how much they're talking
about local issues.
But that would be interesting
to see this dataset
from the Cairo based Data Institute
does go back quite a ways.
Yeah, it'd be interesting to think like,
are there already networks
here that are being activated?
- [Man] That's really interesting to say.
New ones are being activated
during (indistinct).
- Highly repressive time, yeah.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Yeah, that's a great suggestion.
- [Man] I mean, just generally interested
in why did Egypt like
so much of the attention
paid to like the Arab
Spring activity in Egypt
is paid to what's happening in Cairo.
There's just really not a ton
about like, what's happening
in a lot of other areas in Egypt.
Like, I mean, at least in
sort of the popular press,
but then also in like academic literature,
there's not as much.
- Yeah, there's a Jason Brownlee,
I think has written about,
like the Cairo bias in
Egyptian Scholarship,
which I think we're all guilty of,
but particularly with the protests,
I think urban bias is absolutely the case.
And in this case a lot of
these protests didn't happen
in urban centers, which is interesting.
Like, that's not really
the historical pattern
of protests in Egypt.
So yeah, I mean, is it
mobilizing new networks,
is there something about the way
in which like, the regime
has been highly policing
certain areas and not
policing other areas,
and trying to strategize and maximize
the effectiveness of
their repressive capacity.
It's a really interesting question.
We'll definitely do that.
- And maybe because
like, Tyrone has become
such a focal point for the regime
that he opens up space for people
in these smaller communities
to actually organize.
- Yeah, well, in Egypt is
also just a fascinating case,
because you have, if you were to look
at the distribution of population,
it's like, it's a very
concentrated distribution,
which means there are certain ways
in which the regime can
police it very easily,
but it's a huge country at the same time.
And it's not like there aren't people
in the countryside who
are also really unhappy
with what's happening.
And the internet might
be particularly effective
at mobilizing those groups,
relative to like word of mouth
just based on density of population.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Any more question?
- No, we don't have more questions here.
So I think that's it.
So thank you very much
for the presentation
and best of luck with the
remaining of your research.
- Thank you.